foreign
[Music]
just challenged you to an arm wrestle
well lucky for you or perhaps for your
opponent arm wrestling isn't just about
brute strength
[Music]
stand as close to the table as you can
and tuck your elbow into your body
allowing the muscles in your back
shoulder and arm to provide support
when you grip your opponent's hand face
your knuckles directly to the ceiling
creating the highest possible position
for your hand to be in as soon as the
contest starts lean your body back and
pull your hands straight towards your
nose this technique will break open your
Challenger's hand as soon as their grip
begins to slip pull your arm diagonally
towards your other shoulder dropping
your knees and dipping your waist at the
same time
you've just neutralized your rival's
forearm continue rolling your body down
until you inevitably taste victory
foreign